ليست الحرب على الانرو حديثه لكنها الاشد
بالتاكيد منذ سنوات اخر محاور قتال
الوكاله يتمثل في قطع التمويل
عنها تاسست وكاله غوث وتشغيل اللاجئين
الفلسطينيين بعد النكبه ويقتصر عملها مع
اللاجئين ما قبل عام
1967 تعد شريان حياه اكثر من 5ه ملايين
ونصف مليون لاجئ فلسطيني يتوزعون داخل
فلسطين في القدس الشرقيه والضفه وقطاع غزه
وفي دول الشتات بالاردن وسوريا
ولبنان تعتمد الوكاله بشكل كلي على
مساهمات دول اعضاء في الامم المتحده قدرت
ميزانيتها عام 2002
بنحو مليار و2 مليون دولار قدمت الولايات
المتحده النسبه الاكبر بنحو
30% تليها المانيا والاتحاد الاوروبي من
اصل 20 دوله
مانحه تستخدم الاونر ميزانيتها على خمسه
انشطه اساسيه تنفذها في مناطق عملها وهي
التعليم والصحه والاسناد والاغاثه والبنيه
التحتيه في المفهوم السياسي ترمز وكاله
غوث وتشغيل اللاجئين
الفلسطينيين الى وجود فلسطينيين بالدرجه
الاولى خارج ارضهم ووفق القانون الدولي
يحق لهم العوده الى ارض والى
وطن لكن الحمله وصلت ذروه غير مسبوقه خلال
الحرب الاسرائيل
على قطاع غزه ادعت قوات الاحتلال ان كتائب
القسام تستخدم مقر ومدارس الوكاله في
اعمال قتاليه
واحدثها الترويج بالعثور على وثائقه بان
موظفين في طواقمها ينتظمون عسكريا في صفوف
المقاومه وشنت حمله لوقف
التمويل لعبت اسرائيل دور المدعي والقاضي
فامتثل لها عدد من الدول وكرت مسبحه
اعلانات وقف تمويل الاونر دون انتظار
نتائج اي تحقيق رسمي ليصل مجموع التمويل
الضائع بنحو
56% من ميزانيه الوكاله الكليه توالت
انسحابات الدول المانحه بعد ساعات على
قرار صادر عن محكمه الدوليه التي امرت
اسرائيل بضمان ادخال المساعدات
لقطاع
غزه